♪
>>ucker: S SPE 1 YEARS INTH U.S
PLOYMENTIN IQ A
HE IS TH ONL PERN ITHE
WITHDRAW FRO AFGHANISN.R THE DEE
CTICIZEDT AND THE ST
>> ♪♪EW SINEAVI JLNDHE'S PT OF T
>> TS HAS BEE BLDING UOR
IL
ANNE TT H BNHERE A
PERICEDIT, 'S VER PEONALIN THE S
FA APAEFOR OUR EYESA
CIAL MED REATIME
IT W USTRING.
I HAD ARD TEITH IT.DS.
WK PVIOUO IT THE
MMDERF TH MARE COR
ADDRESSI ALL WE RE
IFOU AREAVINTRBLE, SEEK
HE NEROINTED OUT THA ANY
NIOR LDER MIGHT BEULPAE
R WRONOING
WEOULD H AIDED TRO
E THAPIST HAHE AITTE
THATENIO LEADERSAD FAULTS
I S ARY ABOUT HT WA
HALED.
THENIT THAWAS W AACKED
SY FIRNIT A MYEST
ITAMEULLIRCLEOY MOO.
I P THE T.
I KW TS UN.
HAD BECEHE COMMANDE
ALLF THUST GOT TO AIN
ACUNTAE.DERS WOU BE HEL
WASOING TO  HEL
COUNBLE.
ADESSUR SRT FALLSR WEWI KP REPT
STAK.
TH MADE THEID IN M OFFE
D DN'T POS IT RHT AWAY.
WIFE AND T KSN THE
HOE.
LIFEFORER.WLD CNGE UR
THER THEECIOO PUT IT U
>>ucker: B WHY?EVYTHI YOUID, EV
YOUIDT KW Y WOU GTO O
JAIL F IT B Y DID IT
ANYW.
WH
>>HISASEEN M WHOFE.MY WHO ALTIF
DEDICAD TOAMERA.
NO O ISORE PSONAY  ONMANG FEIGNE
INST THAN M
TH'S IELANTHE IM
MEMB W ERY TACCAL
GAGENT ANDHE NATNAL SERITYTRATY
WEON EVE TACCAL LEL
ENGAMENT
PEOPLEEEDO BE HD IS T
THESE JIORLIST ARE
DERVE. EVETHIN AND THEAROTETTI Y
YOUSKEDEHY I DID IT -->>ucke TH
COMMD?
YE I WASHE COMNY
COANDER IULTIE COMMDS.
FORYEARE AMPANYOMMAER
NEXT GHT.BU I DT BECAUSE NOT ON
S PERNALINSTED
LLOWG VIETN NO GENALOFCERSEREEL.
TH HOLEAN UP ERAFT
GENETIONUT THEEVER WEN
CK AND HD TMSELVES
ACCOUNBLE.
TH ECT SAM THING IS
HAENINGIGHT NO
THIS GERATN DOE'T KWOW
FHINA
ND T CHANGEIT.
ACTIC PRLEM.
THEAME THI TTHOUL HAVE
ARE NOREAD A MARGIN SCEN
DESERT SRMN THE'90s AND
THAT THREW US OITH T
CHANS TT NEED TO TE PLACE.
ALF THOEASO ARE WHY-
'S N MYLACE TOAY IT
NOBO EE I SAYIN IIT.
BODYLSE IS SAYING IT.
Tker: REAYREAT AND
NORABLE N.
AT W